[موسيقى]
مع ملايين الأشخاص في أكبر
مدنها في كوريا الجنوبية غالبًا ما تستحضر
صورًا كهذه لحياة عالمية سريعة الخطى
ولكن ما قد لا تعرفه هو أن أكثر
من 60 بالمائة من البلاد
مغطاة بالغابات
مع 22 متنزهًا
وطنيًا ومع  تفرض قيود السفر في جميع أنحاء العالم
عددًا متزايدًا من الكوريين الذين يبحثون عن
استراحة من المدينة الكبيرة ،
وقد أخذت الحياة تتعجب في الهواء الطلق الرائع الخاص بهم ،
فأنت تفعل ذلك عن طريق البر وتطلق عليه اسم
chabak وهو شيء يحدث في
كوريا ، يمكنك الذهاب إليه  في رحلة لمدة يومين
وقتما تشاء دون تحضير
أي شيء أثناء النوم في سيارتك ،
لي سو بن متحمس في الهواء الطلق ،
إنه عربة مخضرمة
يخيم في جميع أنحاء كوريا منذ عدة سنوات
مع زوجته كيم جونغ أوك
، كما يقول تشابا أو التخييم بالسيارة  هو
نشاط بعيد المنال اجتماعيًا
ولهذا السبب أصبح شائعًا جدًا في
العام الماضي
بسبب الوباء ، من الصعب
مقابلة أصدقائك أو الذهاب إلى أماكن مع
العديد من الأشخاص
ولكن مع chabak ، يمكنك  ما زلت أذهب
لزيارة الأماكن أثناء الإقامة في سيارتك
مع عائلتك ، وأعتقد أن هذا هو
السبب في كونه اتجاهًا في كوريا
على عكس التخييم الذي يتطلب الكثير من
الاستعدادات ، يمكنك المغادرة وقتما
تشاء في سيارتك
أيضًا أثناء الوباء حيث
التجمعات الكبيرة  لا يُسمح لك
بالالتزام بالتباعد الاجتماعي نظرًا لأن الجميع
ينام في سيارتهم الخاصة ،
وقد قام لي بتوثيق صور
chabak على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ويقول إن الاهتمام المتزايد
باتجاه التخييم هذا أدى بدوره إلى زيادة
تواجده على الإنترنت بالإضافة إلى
أن لديه حاليًا 12000 متابع  على
Instagram
والآلاف على youtube ،
بدأت في instagram لمشاركة
صور الأماكن بإطلالة رائعة على
الرغم من أنه لم يمر وقت طويل
أحبها الناس ونما الحساب
بسرعة كبيرة
ولم يكن الوحيد الذي
تمت مشاهدة بعض مقاطع الفيديو الكورية الخاصة بالتخييم
مئات الآلاف من المرات من قبل
المشاهدين في جميع أنحاء العالم
يقول لي إنه مع قيود السفر في
جميع أنحاء العالم
، رأى اهتمامًا أكبر من
المستخدمين الدوليين
كثيرًا جدًا  إذا أرسل الأجانب رسائل يسألون
عن الأماكن
وتوصياتنا ونخبرهم عنها بالنسبة لي ،
أصبح الوباء فرصة لزوجتي
وأنا لتجربة سفر المغامرة
معًا
لأنني أحب التقاط الصور وأعتقد أنها
كانت فرصة جيدة لتقديم
هذه الأماكن  للآخرين
أيضًا وهو أكثر من سعيد لمشاركة
تجربة
التخييم العادية ، فهي محدودة حيث
يمكنني إنشاء خيام
ومعدات للشباك على الرغم من أنه يمكنني الذهاب إلى أي مكان
حيث يمكن لسيارتي الذهاب
لذلك أعتقد أن هذا هو سحر تشابك
لك